over 150 billion dollars in three days
that's how much the world's 15 largest
cryptocurrencies lost in market value
it's because of the crypto exchange
platform FTX which is behind this token
named ftt on November 6th the token's
value began to fall losing more than 80
percent of its worth in the span of 72
hours once seen as a survivor in a
struggling Market the fall of FTX has
sent shockwaves through the
cryptocurrency industry so what went
wrong
[Music]
FTX is the brainchild of Sam bankman
freed he's commonly known as SBF on
social media he's been previously hailed
as a savior of the crypto industry and
you were called the JP Morgan of crypto
did that bother you or did not it
doesn't bother me too much Beckman freed
founded the quantitative trading firm
Alameda research in 2017. two years
later he started FTX an exchange
platform for buying or selling
cryptocurrencies right now he's the
majority owner of both firms that kind
of aroused some skepticism among
industry players and Traders investors
stakeholders that there could be some
sort of conflict of interest in terms of
whether Alameda research was getting
preferential treatment or FDX vice versa
but the official narrative thus SPF gave
in the past is that the two companies
are separate entities after its launch
FTX attracted major investments from
Silicon Valley and Wall Street you know
we'd raised a few billion dollars over
the course of last last couple years and
were profitable business it grew into
the fourth largest cryptocurrency
exchange for derivatives trading
celebrities promoted the platform in ads
I'm getting into crypto with FTX you win
it's FTX it's a safe and easy way to get
into crypto
yeah I don't think so FTX was gaining
state
process often tussled with
the world's largest crypto
crypto by volume when FTX was getting
started binance invested in FTX and it
was one of the crypto exchanges earliest
investors but FTX as we know grew really
rapidly and became a very substantial
rival to binance as FTX grew in the
industry bankman freed furthered his
reputation as a crypto savior when
digital asset prices collapsed earlier
this year it's not fair to customers he
bailed out firms spending about a
billion dollars it's okay to do a deal
that is modern certainly bad in in
bailing out a place but that image
didn't last on November 2nd coindesk
published a report based on a leaked
Alameda balance sheet according to the
leaked data Alameda claimed it had over
14 billion dollars in assets at the end
of June but most of that was ftx's
tokens Alameda CEO Caroline Ellison
tweeted that the balance sheet wasn't
complete Caroline also said its
financial situation is under control the
company is doing well however it seems
like the market just didn't really buy
that and then Traders continued to
withdraw from FTX FTX and alhameda did
not respond to a request for comment
things escalated on November 6th when
binance said it would offload hundreds
of millions of dollars of ftt Finance
did not respond to a request for comment
the announcement sparked Mass
withdrawals that day FTX processed four
billion dollars of transactions many
times the normal amount for for a day
some got backlogged which sparked demand
for more by November 7th that number
ballooned to 6 billion dollars on the
eighth a day later ftx's finances were
in crisis binance stepped in and said it
would buy the company it seemed like FTX
might have solved its liquidity problem
but on the ninth binance backed out of
the non-binding acquisition the next day
the journal reported that FTX used money
from customers to fund risky bets made
by Alameda it's a shocking Revelation
for a lot of people in the industry
because even though there has been a lot
of speculation about FDX and Alameda
research being joined at the hip nobody
could have foreseen that SBF was willing
to transfer billions of customer funds
at the his crypto exchange to help his
crypto trading firm the Securities and
Exchange Commission and justice
department are investigating FTX
according to a person familiar with the
matter this is not like the New York
Stock Exchange or NASDAQ they take
people's money they borrow against it
it's it's not much disclosure and then
they trade against their customers a
spokesperson for the justice department
declined to comment Beckman freed told
investors that FTX couldn't cover
withdrawals since its collateral was
dropping in value and couldn't be
liquidated according to people familiar
with the matter on the 11th bankman
freed resigned as CEO and FTX and
Alameda filed for bankruptcy
afterwards FTX said it was probing a
potential hack more than 370 million
dollars worth of crypto funds appeared
to be missing according to crypto
analytics firm elliptic on the 12th the
journal reported that Alameda and FTX
Executives knew that FTX had lent its
customers money to Alameda so a lot of
retail Traders and investors I've talked
to are feeling desperate or frustrated
the majority of the people in the
industry could not have seen this coming
because FTX is such a dominant player
The Fallout has led other companies to
tout their reserves and call for more
transparency in the industry as of
November 11th according to the
bankruptcy filing ftx's estimation of
their liabilities would make it the
largest crypto related bankruptcy ever
filed
foreign